Welcome, friends.
Come hang out with me while I milk my cow.
First thing, I need to unload some feedable yesterday.
And very important step.
Turn off the fence.
I'm waiting for Cora to get in her trained position
before she gets to feed.
And now she gets a reward.
She gets a layered feed bowl of stock feed,
oats, and cracked corn.
She also gets bar switches,
black oil, sunflower seeds,
and some minerals.
And I layer it all so it's kinda mixed together
so I don't have to premix it.
Now I'm going to sanitize and wash her teeth.
They're not really dirty,
so I'm just gonna sanitize them.
I have soap and a bleach wash here in my bucket.
Then I'm gonna spray out her teats
just to get rid of the milk that's already in her tea.
And give her a little dry.
Make sure those nips are dry.
Now I'm going to set up my milk machine.
I got this from minisupply,
and it's a German brand and can't say the name,
but hey ho, it's a great machine.
And here I am setting it up.
It's nice and clean,
but when I cleaned it yesterday,
one of the cups here,
I put a plug in
because one of her quarters is not milking right now.
You can hear the machine,
but I actually lowered the sound
because it's really loud
once it's on.
I just let it do its thing and suck up the Milk.
The machine does a great job
of pulling the milk out of her others.
As she has such small teeth,
kinda hard to handle her.
This machine can fully milk her out in a few minutes.
Her left side of her utter always creates more milk.
And you can see here that it's still bulging.
Once I'm feeling it's kind of looser,
I'm gonna take the claw off
to make sure I don't open. Milk.
Look at that delicious milk.
Now it's time to clean.
I'm gonna using dish soap.
There's already some bleach in the bucket.
And suck all that through
to rinse and sanitize out the milk.
I'm gonna get a rinse to get rid of all the soap.
And then I'm gonna rinse through with a acid wash.
Right now I'm using vinegar.
You can use a dairy acid as well.
I'm gonna rinse all that milk out
and make sure there's no soap left over.
And then I'm gonna let it set to dry for tomorrow.
Need to make sure I turn the fence back on
cause sometimes I forget.
And now it's time to take the milk back to the house.
This is my milking area
where I like to bottle all my milk.
And the kids like to just use it at the dumping area.
So here I am
having to clean and sanitize it before I start bottling.
And today I'm bottling for myself.
So I'm gonna use a few different types. Of bottles.
I have about two gallons of milk,
and this is the. What I'm picking today.
This is the filters that I use is a dairy milk filter.
This is specifically designed to filter milk,
and I'm gonna put it on my milk strainer here,
which fits perfectly on top of a Mason jar.
I have a few strainers,
but this one works pretty well for Mason jars.
Now just have to dump it into the bottles
and filter the milk.
Once the milk's done filtering,
I can see on the screen of the filter
to see if there's anything
like mastitis or anything I need to be aware of.
And right now,
she's healthy and there's no issues.
So this milk is good to consume.
1.
It was starting to get pretty hot in the sunroom,
so I turned my mystical heater off.
Actually really like these jars that I'm pouring.
This one, the square jar,
I got this from Walmart,
and it was really cheap,
and it has the lid attached to it,
so I never have to go find lids.
Then I'm gonna retrieve my hidden sharpie
and write the day on all the jars.
I write the day of today,
the day that the cow was melt.
And the milk will be good for about two weeks out
from this date.
Then I went to retrieve some lids,
because I never have any lids around.
They're always just like.
Just got the dishwasher.
And I just throw them in the drawer.
I'm going to wipe the bottom of the jar
so I don't get milk in the fridge.
And here is a quick milk fridge shot.
And that's how I milk my cow once per day.